Clashes are erupting
on the streets of Paris
amid mayday protests.
A CNN team
on the ground have witnessed fireworks.
Other projectiles
being thrown as police
who answered with tear gas is.
Take a look.
It looks like a rainy day
in Paris right now and
looks like their clashes are erupting
once again.
Taking a live look. Look, May Day.
May 1st is a day
treated as a holiday in many countries
to support
to a sorry.
The controller
and speaking to
Mayday is often celebrated
with demonstrations
as a holiday to recognize labor rights.
It is hitting differently this time.
This May 1st in Paris
because this is coming against continued
kind of outrage and controversy
over French
President Macron's move to reform
and overhaul the pension system there,
which also included
raising the retirement age by two years.
Melissa Bell is on the street
for us in Paris.
She's joining us now,
I think, on the phone.
Melissa, if you can hear me,
tell me what you're seeing
up there.
Kate,
what we're
seeing here
at the very front of the protest.
This is where the black bloc
traditionally see confrontation
with the police.
And as you can see,
that's exactly what's happening today
compared to the last few protests
when we've been out here
for pension
reform,
we've seen a lot more of these black folk
than we had in
many of the other protests.
And I think that's
why you're seeing it get
so confrontational
with the police so early on.
There's an awful lot of tear
gas in the air.
There's been a lot of projectiles
going back and forth
and some pretty violent clashes already.
This is just the very front
of the protest.
Kate.
Oh, so sorry.
Melissa.
You're doing okay, Melissa.
The teargas,
the teargas, the teargas is so heavy
Kate out there,
I can barely breathe, but it's all right.
Just, you know what?
Know, this is,
of course, the very front of the protest.
As I was saying a moment ago,
this is the very front of the protest.
And the idea is that the black bloc,
as they leave things off, try and see
confrontation from the police,
as you can see today.
That's what they've been doing
fairly successfully.
I love a lot of them out in the streets
here.
12,000 policemen on the streets
trying to keep these marches peaceful.
Kate, this is also traditionally made
the first.
This is a day
when people come out to protest.
In any case.
So the police had expected
this particular day
because the pension reform protests
we've seen
that have gotten so vital
in these last few weeks to be even better
attended
than some of the protest
we've seen recently
and possibly
the best attended May the first protest
we've seen in many, many years.
Certainly,
they're proving to be some of the most
animated at so far
and very early on in the day
that we've seen in a long time, Kate.
Absolutely.
And we're going to stick with you
as long as we can.
And please tell me how you're feeling,
because everyone can understand
how impossible it can be
to continue to report live
when you have tear
gas filling your lungs.
But talk to me,
because this
you and I
have had this conversation over.
Now it's over
weeks of Macron had proposed this.
The protesters came out.
The constant
the equivalent of the Supreme Court
in France
then said that this
these reforms can go through.
So what what are they
what going to happen
now, despite all these flash bangs
that I'm hearing behind you
That's right, Kate.
I mean, that's the point.
This is happening right from September.
The French will incrementally start
working more and more each year.
Until they reach their retirement age
by 20.
30 of 64,
pretty low by European standards.
But here in France, a very soft nerve,
as you can see.
And the way that Emmanuel Macron
carried it out.
You mentioned a moment ago
the Constitutional Council,
by pushing it through
without a parliamentary vote,
has really added to a lot of the anger.
Now, A lot of the people
that you're seeing around me
here are the black bloc.
These are the most
some of the most extreme elements
you're talking about,
the very far left
that come out of these protests
seeking confrontation with the police,
the vast majority of the protesters
that are following in the march.
I think it's important
to add the trade unions,
the people have come out here
to peacefully demonstrate
or in the vast vast majority.
But the point is that
all of the people out here
on the streets today,
whether they are the black bloc,
whether they are
the more peaceful protesters behind me,
know that they're coming out
to protest against a pension reform
that may be going through,
but it is vastly opposed
by a majority of the French population.
So it is something like 62% of the French
that are opposed to this reform.
And I think most importantly, Kate,
one of the most interesting statistics
is that since this began on January 19th,
the protests, the strikes,
they've now continued
for all of those months
with all of the trouble
and the difficulty in the chaos
and the gridlock
that that brings to French people
the popular support in favor
of this movement,
in favor of this protest movement,
has actually risen by 11%.
So that is really what
the people out here
on the street are hoping to tap into.
The fact
that the French
are extremely angry about this reform
and that anger has appeared to grow
and as we're all
seeing, the police line moving
just passed past Melissa and her team.
There was a stay safe.
We're going to
we're going to check back with you
as these as we've seen.
And then then they rush in
to kind of move the line
and to move the protesters back.
We've seen
we saw this since we've been talking
to Melissa
over the weeks of these protests,
how they can flare up
really, really quickly.
And we've been seeing projectiles,
fireworks, tear
gas being responded back and forth.
Melissa, thank you so much.
We're going to get close
to Melissa and her team in Paris.
See how this continues developing.